معنى من موسكو مدير ومكتبه الجزيره زاور
شاوج زاور لو بدانا معك بالعقيده السياسيه
الخارجيه لروسيا التي وقعها الرئيس بوتين
اليوم ما اثرها وانعكاسها المباشر وماذا
ايضا في تفاعلات تصريحات الرئيس
البيلاروسي
نعم حسنا اذا بدا
نا تم تبنيها في عام 2021 وطلب بوتين
اجراء تعديلات عليها بعد بدا روسيا حربها
في اوكرانيا فيمكن باختصارها في جمل قصيره
جدا ان روسيا في سياستها الخارجيه ستعمل
من اجل انهاء ما وصفته بالهيم ما تبقى
بالهيم الهيمنه الامريكيه في العالم وانها
ستعمل بشكل كبير من اجل منع حدوث اي
مواجهه باستخدام اسلحه النوويه واسلحه
الدمار الشامل ولكن ايضا في نفس العقيده
ابرز التوجهات روسيا الخارجيه
لسنوات القادمه وهي العلاقه الاستراتيجيه
مع الصين والهند العلاقه مع دول امريكا
اللاتينيه ومع دول العربيه والافريقيه
ولكن على الرغم من تحدث هذه العقيده
بنسختها الجديده عن ان الخطر الاكبر ياتي
بالدرجه الاولى من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الا انها ايضا قدمت حسن نفسها
روسيا انها لا تعتبر موسكو نفسها عدوه
للعالم
الغربيه وانها تعول على عوده تدريجيه
لاحقا لتنسيق مع الدول الغربيه بما يتماشى
مع مبدا المساواه واحترام المصالح هذا
فيما يتعلق بالشغل العقيده
عقيده السياسه الخارجيه ولكن طبعا تصريحات
الرئيس
بيلاروسيا كانت لها اصادا كبير خاصه هنا
في روسيا مع تقديمه المقترح الذي تحدثت
عنه عنه في الخبر وتحدث عنه في كلمته
الرئيس البيلاروسيا الذي يتضمن وقفا
لاطلاق النار وتجميد النزاع دون تحريك اي
قوات او معدات عسكريه والتحدث عن او كشف
ربما اسرار لاول مره يقولها الرئيس
بيلاروسي بان الجانبين اي القوات على
الارض لا تريد ان تحارب لانها ان كانت على
الجانب الاوكراني او على الجانب الروسي لا
تعرف من اجل اي شيء تقاتل في هذه المعركه
ولكن ايضا تحدث بشكل مفصل اليوم في خطابه
الذي مستمر حتى الان منذ اربع ساعات
تقريبا على تهديدات التي تواجه بيلاروسيا
تحديدا من الدول الغربيه وحشود حلف شمال
الاطلسي عند حدود روسيا وطلبه من بوتين ان
تعود الاسلحه النوويه التي تخلت عنها
بيلاروسيا في تسعينيات عام الماضي الاسلحه
ليست التكتيكيه وانما الاستراتيجيه وربما
هنا ستاتي نعم حسنا يعني نقطتان رئيسيتان
ذكرهما
الاولى المتعلقه بالهدنه
لكنها كما هو واضح هي هدنه مشروطه باليات
معينه ومساله عوده الاسلحه النوويه الى
بيلاروسيا التي سبق ان تخلت عنها هاتان
النقطتان كيف
تتجاوب معهما موسكو
طبعا ربما اذا عدنا حتى ليس فقط الى
تصريحات روسيا ولا حتى التصريحات الغربيه
الكل ينظر الى ان روسيا تريد تجويد نزاع
المقترح البيلاروسيا وقف اطلاق النار بدون
اي شروط وجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات بدون
اي شروط حتى ان لوكيشنكي حسن يستخدم تعبير
تجميد النزاع وهذا طبعا امر يرفضه الجانب
الغربي وترفضه ربما روسيا في جزئيه ان
تحقيق اهداف العمليه العسكريه يتم فقط عبر
الاساليب العسكريه وهذا ما تكرره القياده
الروسيه منذ ايام اما فيما يتعلق بالسلاح
النووي طبعا هذا التطور كبير خاصه اذا
وافقت روسيا نحن لا نعلم لحد الان الموقف
الروسي من هذه الكلمات كلمات لوكيشنكا لان
هذا يعني ان هناك تجاوز التزامات اخذتها
على عاتقها روسيا في تسعينات القرن الماضي
بتدمير ترى النوويه البيلاروسيه التي حصلت
عليها بعد ان يرى الاتحاد وايضا فيما
يتعلق بمعاهدات عدم الانتشار النووي
وانتشار اسلحه الدمار الشامل التي اكد
الرئيس الروسي قبل ايام ان روسيا ستلتزم
بها وذلك في ضوء حديثه عن تسليم اوكرانيا
اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه ولكن من الواضح ان
الرئيس البينسي يتحدث عن الاسلحه النوويه
الاستراتيجيه وليس الاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه التي اصبحت بالفعل كما علمنا
على الاراضي البيلاروسيه حسن شكرا جزيلا
لك شاويش مدير مكتب الجزيره حدثتنا من مصر